ea sports had a problem in the form of
litigation that arose
because they had a college football game
that was not compensating the players
whose names
images and likenesses would work into
the game and i remember buying that game
back
i don't know 10 15 years ago and the
west virginia players
you knew who they were even though their
names weren't on the back of their
jerseys they were the same size they
were the same shape they had the same
attributes when you gave a guy the
football and he took off you knew
that that was the starting running back
so uh shireen
now that we're moving toward players
being able to get paid
for their names image and likenesses
college football is coming back now
it's not coming back this year but it's
coming back at some point i think
shireen they're trying to get
the guts of this in place the
infrastructure in place
so once they figure out how to properly
pay the kids and compensate them
for their names their image and their
likenesses they'll be able to fire up
the game and get it to market quickly
so i don't play video games tell me
if it's like johnny manziel can he be on
this game or is it all current
college players how does it work well i
know what they do with the madden game
they have a bunch of
past players who are available in this
ultimate team mode that is extremely
popular
what they can do is have current teams
and
what you could then do is go out and
acquire the rights to the former players
and that's not an issue because
you can acquire rights and i don't know
what they pay i've heard
terrell owens complain it's not very
much but you can get the rights to use
the name the image and the likeness of a
former player like a johnny manziel
i i saw a mock-up of a cover with trevor
lawrence on it you can pay him at this
point
to be on the cover of an ncaa video game
so i think it would be a combination
they do it like the nfl where you've got
current teams plus you can do
historical players and make your own you
know put them on
on texas a m if it's a player who played
for texas you you know you do it
that way so it'd be a combination but
for the current players that's the
problem that's the impediment and that's
why they haven't had it
in seven years because of the liability
risk
because if you're going to do it without
the names and the likenesses
and the images of the players properly
licensed to you you're going to have to
work on every team to make sure there's
no way
that anyone's going to think that the
guy who's playing quarterback is
supposed to be
the guy who's actually playing
quarterback for that team so that's
where it becomes a challenge but it
looks like they're gonna get ready
at some point to start making all the
money that they make off of other
major video games like madden like the
fifa game and
it's been a long time without college
football i know there's a lot of people
excited about it but still i hope that
the players
the current players will be properly
compensated when this comes back
because they aren't properly compensated
frankly
for the sacrifices they make and the
risks they take in playing college
football
so is this your is west virginia going
to be your dynasty team mike when it
comes back
you know i i'm still partial to madden
so
uh i'm probably gonna stick with madden
and and
if the game is at all realistic west
virginia will stink
so uh or not be nearly as good as it
once was
so i'll probably just stick i'll
probably just stick with madden